[Música]
en france 24 es momento de hablar de
ciencia y tecnología soy valentina torre
sánchez y es un gusto acompañarlos
iniciamos este espacio hablando de la
lucha contra el vih son múltiples las
iniciativas que buscan que las personas
que están contagiadas puedan tener más
opciones y opciones más cómodas de
tratamiento en reino unido- estudian una
alternativa con inyecciones que serviría
para reemplazar una parte de las
pastillas que estas personas deben tomar
a diario para mantener muy bajos los
niveles del virus
y ofrecer el beneficio de poder elegir
un tratamiento para el vih hacia uno de
los grandes éxitos de la medicina
moderna nets
espero llevar esto a un siguiente nivel
reduciendo el tratamiento de 365 días a
6 en un año es realmente un cambio de
paradigmas están en break 3 los
responsables de la iniciativa explican
que el tratamiento inyectable es una
combinación de cabo tegra beer y
rilpivirina y únicamente está
recomendado para personas que mediante
antirretrovirales diarios ya han logrado
mantener una carga viral baja los
medicamentos han sido probados durante
dos años en 16 países y muestran que al
aplicarlos una vez al mes son tan
eficaces como las píldoras diarias
cuando fui diagnosticado originalmente
no había absolutamente nada era una
sentencia de muerte
en ese momento me dieron seis meses de
vida pero ahora hay gran cantidad de
medicamentos efectivos
y dejamos atrás este tema y vamos a perú
donde un grupo de arqueólogos halló una
momia de entre 1.200 y mil 800 años de
antigüedad se trata de restos de la
época pre inca que habrían pertenecido a
un hombre que murió entre los 18 y 22
años y fueron encontrados cuando
excavaban en un milenario complejo
urbano de barro en la periferia de lima
hemos logrado el descubrimiento de una
momia que se encontraba ubicada al
interior de una estructura funeraria de
forma cónica subterránea y bueno
el verbo de la característica se trataba
de una momia que se encontraba amarrada
con su villano es una característica
peculiar y única de este contexto
funerario la característica de los
materiales que estaban asociados al
entierro nos hacen ver pues que era una
persona dedicada a la agricultura porque
se han encontrado restos de maíz y otro
producto botánico de agua lo que estiman
los expertos la forma en la que se
produjo el entierro da a entender que se
trata de una persona de la sierra que
llegó a la zona donde fue enterrada con
propósitos comerciales
vamos ahora a reino unido donde una
empresa emergente satélite view está
probando una tecnología con satélites
infrarrojos que permitirían emitir
información en tiempo real sobre los
gases contaminantes que emitan hogares
locales comerciales pequeños o empresas
el próximo año lanzaremos nuestro primer
satélite pero en total nuestro objetivo
es enviar una constelación de siete
satélites que estarán en órbitas
ligeramente diferentes así tendremos la
capacidad de capturar imágenes hasta 20
veces por día o por la noche es decir
casi cada hora esencialmente para
recopilar información sobre objetivos
puntuales por lo tanto podremos ver
cambios bastante drásticos pudiendo
detectar objetos y medir esos cambios en
cada instalación a través del cielo
hoyle actualmente la compañía usa un
pequeño avión para hacer pruebas con
esta tecnología que según los
responsables también serviría para
identificar vertimientos contaminantes
en el mar o en los ríos los responsables
aseguran que su iniciativa permitiría
monitorear con más exactitud que se
cumplan los compromisos adquiridos en la
cumbre climática de glasgow la cob 26 de
mantener el calentamiento global en
máximo 15 grados hasta el final del
siglo
ha habido un impulso real en el mundo
para llevar la humanidad a un futuro más
amigable con el medio ambiente y parte
de eso se basará en aumentar la
eficiencia energética de nuestros
edificios y reducir la cantidad de
energía que usamos dentro de ellos por
ello nuestros satélites serán capaces de
medir la cantidad de energía térmica que
se emite desde cualquier estructura de
la tierra en varios momentos del día o
la noche
finalizamos en seúl la capital
surcoreana donde el gobierno local está
probando alfa mini un robot de 24
centímetros que se desempeña como
profesor para los niños que van al
jardín les enseña canciones recita
historias e incluso enseña movimientos
básicos de kung fu
con you see que ahora hemos enviado
estos robots a 60 jardines cada mes así
que desde agosto 240 jardines los han
tenido durante un mes que siguen
no creemos que los robots vayan a
reemplazar a los profesores sino que los
asistirán jordi nadal y daniel soto
después del programa piloto de este año
y tras continuar en 2022 tendremos que
desarrollar un manual sobre el rol del
robot
para los responsables del gobierno
metropolitano la experiencia con alfa
mini es clave para que los niños se
familiaricen con la tecnología que ahora
es considerada de última generación pues
para ellos vendrán muchos más avances
que se acelerarán con el pasar de los
años el robot puede guiñar los ojos y
sus pupilas se convierten en corazones
durante una conversación cuenta con una
cámara en su casco y puede tomar fotos
que se envían instantáneamente a
dispositivos como una tableta en el
piloto del gobierno está destinado a
interactuar con niños de entre 3 y 5
años así llegamos al final de este
espacio a ustedes gracias por su
sintonía los invitamos a continuar con
nosotros en france 24 y france24 punto
com
no